foreign
for these families I have a friend in
Nashville so I knew of one of the little
girls and the thought that any of us
could send our children and not get to
hug them again my kids go to school
right next to a school where there was a
shooting Melissa Joan Hart mom to three
boys ages 10 15 and 17 says she wound up
aiding fleeing students all of a sudden
I saw a bunch of a teacher on that this
is the part I'll never forget the look
on her face just
changed my life so I got out of the car
and I went and helped these children
across the street somehow I found out
this was a kindergarten class and this
little girl looks at me she said what
are we what are we doing or what's going
on what's going on like it was literally
like a mama duck and her little ducks
like running across the street 200
police cars had come I mean the sirens
the it was just insane it was the
saddest thing I've ever witnessed we've
been here a week in 2020 we visited
Melissa at home just after she moved her
family to Nashville hoping for an
exciting new chapter now she's reminded
of the place and the other tragedy she
thought she had left behind we moved
here from Connecticut where we were in a
school a little ways down from Sandy
Hook so this is our second experience
with a school shooting I went and picked
the kids up immediately and they're home
safe
what is happening in the world in tear
singer Jesse James Decker shared that
her three little ones were at another
school just two miles away and former
Olympian Sean Johnson says she was just
across the street when the chaos ensued
this was the emotional reunion with her
two kids after getting a call that their
school was on lockdown being a parent
personally makes me feel like I've like
fulfilled a purpose that I never knew I
had
foreign